what is going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder I'm Warren Thompson
and we have a lot of Hulk news coming
out recently yesterday we got word that
She-Hulk season two is going to be
coming after the writer strike ends and
today we have some news about what world
war Hulk could actually be like and why
it could actually start in the first
place if you are unaware Marvel Studios
now finally has the rights back to make
a solo Hulk film these rights were held
by Universal for a very long time that's
why you always saw the Hulk and other
movies with other Heroes but ever since
the Incredible Hulk we've never had
another solo Hulk film because legally
Marvel Studios was not allowed to create
one however that has all changed and we
have a new Hulk movie coming a solo Hulk
movie coming however a solo Hulk movie
might not be the best way to describe it
as it appears there are going to be many
different hulks in this film now
insiders have been saying for about a
year now that the next Hulk film is
going to be a World War Hulk film World
War Hulk is an incredible story from
Marvel Comics but Marvel Studios is not
going to adapt the same exact story that
we know from the comics in fact it
sounds like it's going to be quite
different than the comic story it sounds
like it could be a great story but not
many aspects from the comic storyline
are gonna make it over to the MCU it
sounds like however we could be
experiencing an all-out war in World War
Hulk hence the name and it sounds like
Savage Hulk is going to be returning no
more Professor Hulk no more Bruce Banner
in control of the Hulk but Savage Hulk
breaking free and going crazy which is
what fans have been wanting to see for a
pretty long time now so don't worry
we're gonna break down everything you
need to know in this video and of course
if you're new be sure to subscribe so
you don't miss out on any of the latest
videos and there are only two days left
in our giveaway if you want a chance to
win an Xbox series X A PS5 so Marvel
Legends items or some DC items all you
have to do is subscribe and leave a
comment down below it is at the end of
this month so as I mentioned yesterday
it's been revealed that a She-Hulk
season 2 is going to be coming after the
strike's end and although some fans
might not be excited about this it is
going to be pretty important because I
believe it is going to lead up to World
War Hulk in fact when the first season
of She-Hulk came out we had already
gotten word that Marvel Studios was
planning a World War Hulk movie and then
in the final episode of She-Hulk Bruce
Banner's Hulk returned with his son Scar
from sakar which is where the Hulk gets
sent to in the world war Hulk storyline
in the comics but his son showing up
another Hulk showing up kind of gave us
the idea that world war Hulk was
starting at this point a new story for
the Hulk is going to be told and his son
is going to be a part of that story now
in the comics his son is kind of a part
of that story not really but he believes
that his wife and his unborn child that
she is pregnant with his son die his
wife does indeed die but he goes on to
find out way later on that his son
actually lived but it it is because he
thinks his wife and his son have died
that he goes absolutely crazy goes back
to Earth and essentially makes all of
the heroes his slaves and the entire
reason that he was on sakhar in the
first place is because the Illuminati
banished him they thought he was too
dangerous to keep on Earth so they
tricked him and they sent him off into
space in a spaceship until he landed on
sakkar now this kind of happened in Thor
Ragnarok Hulk ended up on sakar after
the events of Avengers Age of Ultron and
he became Gladiator Hulk and Bruce
Banner was pushed away right now in the
MCU it's the opposite Bruce Banner is in
control he is partially the Hulk but
Savage Hulk hasn't been there in a while
and this is something that fans haven't
exactly been pleased about but it sounds
like he's going to be coming back and
this is going to be what starts World
War Hulk I believe the report of savage
Hulk returning comes from The Insider
can we get some toast and yesterday in a
response to this tweet please tell me if
we are getting the Savage Hulk back soon
they stated Savage Hulk's rage has been
festering what happens when smart Hulk
loses himself to his rage now many fans
will be excited to hear this because
many fans miss an actual real Savage
Hulk and whether Marvel Studios was
listening to the fans complain about it
or this was their plan the entire time
it's good to know that he will be
returning and if you remember in
She-Hulk season 1 Bruce Banner talked
about a device that keeps him in control
over the Hulk that keeps him smart Hulk
what happens if whatever mechanism that
he has built to keep himself in control
fails well Savage Hulk would come out
but this tweet brings up an excellent
point the rage that Savage Hulk has has
to still be there and you would imagine
that since he is trapped that rage is
growing more and more and more and all
of a sudden if Bruce Banner cannot
control that rage anymore and it gets
let loose what is going to happen to the
Hulk and the world well as expected and
as we hope the Hulk will go crazy true
Hulk again and Bruce Banner is going to
to have no control this could be what
starts World War Hulk just a true Hulk
Rampage and other hulks trying to stop
him some good some bad one of course
being his cousin She-Hulk the other
possibly being his son depending on what
route they want to go with his son's
scar because in the comics he hates him
for a very long time scar hates the Hulk
and wants to kill him but of course it's
the MCU and they don't really do
complete comic adaptations but we do
know that red Hulk is going to be in the
MCU and we do know that red Hulk is also
going to be the president of the United
States Thunderbolt Russ and we know that
he has still been experimenting with
super soldier serum and it's actually a
cool thought to think about the Hulk
goes out of control and starts
destroying everything of course we'll
start with New York since that's where
the Hulk we assume is going to be maybe
California since that's the last place
that we saw him but imagine the Hulk
getting so out of control that the
president himself steps up and goes fine
I'll do it myself then possibly has some
of his subjects that he's probably been
experimenting on with super soldier
serum possibly other hulks a system as
well because I don't think a new Hulk a
new Red Hulk is going to be able to go
toe-to-toe with a full-on enraged Hulk
that is exploding because he has been
kept a prisoner for years now this Hulk
is pretty much going to be unstoppable
and I don't think it's actually going to
be a fight that stops him I'm pretty
sure it's going to be something like his
son or his cousin and there's a good
reason for this ultimately I don't think
anybody can really defeat the Hulk in
the comic story at the end he is so
filled with rage and gamma radiation
that it literally starts spewing from
his mouth he takes a step on the ground
and it shatters the Earth beneath him he
slaps the ground with his hand in the
entire Earth shakes he is literally
about to destroy the world simply by
walking so he tells Tony to use his
Ultimate Weapon to stop him and Tony art
calls down a satellite blast and it hits
the Hulk and he reverts back to Bruce
Banner then Shield comes in and they
lock him up and I think something very
similar is going to probably happen in
this movie now obviously this isn't
going to be like a World War Hulk story
in the comics it's going to be different
and the world war Hulk is probably
referring to a battle between hulks one
is a battle between Bruce Banner and
Savage Hulk or Professor Hulk and Savage
Hulk and then Red Hulk and then of
course She-Hulk I'm assuming there could
be a lot of others as well and if we are
going to get incursions involved in this
there could be other variants of Hulk
there could be a maestro Hulk that comes
in from Another Universe with the
Multiverse and with incursions happening
really anything is possible which means
that this movie could truly be pretty
fantastic and of course even if the Hulk
gets locked up he's gonna be needed
again eventually of course and I'm
assuming that's going to be the King
Dynasty because I don't see a scenario
where the Hulk loses to another Hulk and
hopefully that is what happens he does
not lose he goes full rage what we've
been waiting for and maybe it takes
something like Iron Man technology to
bring him back or perhaps his son's scar
but perhaps Roadie has access to some
machine that Tony Stark built to try to
contain the Hulk we've already kind of
seen that before think Age of Ultron but
I for one am really excited and I think
a lot of people are going to be really
excited as well to hear that the Savage
Hulk the true Hulk that we know full on
enraged Hulk is going to be returning to
the Marvel Cinematic Universe let us
know your thoughts about this and your
best theories about this about what
could happen to set the Hulk off to make
him finally break free of Professor Hulk
and become the true Hulk again in the
comments down below don't forget to like
this video And subscribe so you don't
miss out on any of the latest MCU news
and don't forget only two days left in
the giveaway so subscribe and leave a
comment down below to enter you can
always follow us on Instagram and
Twitter as well and as always thank you
all so much for watching woof woof